here's something I've learned over the
years you need a set up for an Arrested
Development cliff because the show takes
so many twists and turns
especially your character yeah yeah yeah
is this which cook you're in the attic
oh yes you know what I can I don't even
know how to explain this we know your
Buster has a yeah he lost and a while
ago but he it got eaten by a seal he
gots eaten by a seal that happens yeah
yeah I remember actually going up to
Mitch Hurwitz because he's such a
talented guy Andy was on the show yeah
and and I had an idea of her and I was
like oh what if you know Buster was on
like Dancing with the Stars he was like
yeah I'm thinking about a seal biting
off your hand but anyway a bit of my
hand and then this clip Michael
discovers me in the Attic it's really
hard to even give it I don't even know
why you and you why your address where
you are but you know actually I can't
even remember okay okay what a great
setup take a look at this clip from
Arrested Development Buster Buster hey
fortunately this wasn't Michaels first
scuba scare ya hey Michael hi know that
much of a monster man who even to you no
no not at all I I just I wasn't
expecting you know a man to bleed
sitting in a scuba Junior leaping out at
me up in the attic that's all
[Laughter]
look at that got new hand I just took
this skin off go to the dryer
[Music]
the state man
you